gentlemen we're live are we live okay
fantastic so
folks we have a the legendary gianni
russo from some who would call uh the
greatest movie of all time and a lot of
experts would call it the greatest movie
of all time godfather two he played
cardinal follow one god sorry godfather
one two
godfather one godfather one godfather
two but godfather one
with the legendary scene the legendary
scene which maybe we'll get into that uh
and uh what's crazy about today gianni
that kind of makes us think crazy
uh
today is international woman's day as
adam was saying yes and we couldn't have
anybody but we had the international
women's day with a
i said former player you said when did i
stop yeah
when did you ever start i'm still
playing i'm out there but you're a lover
not a fighter and the godfather you were
kind of an abusive husband but in real
life you're a lover
that was in the script believe me
barzini told me to do it but i think we
had we had to get
sonny to the toll boats
so what we're going to do today adam and
i are going to try to do a scene from a
movie yeah and we're going to see if
you're going to remember the scene from
this movie maybe you won't recognize but
we're going to try to something to
re-enact
with this scene
he's going to so we'll see how far into
we can go with our acting folks stick
around you know this could be our
opportunity to pick up a movie or
something but uh while we're doing this
a lot of stuff's going on in the world
gas prices right now california as of
what yesterday
528 a gallon
highest ever in the state of california
says triple a
uh folks around the country are
struggling with gas prices us just
announced biden this morning that we
can't buy gas from russia that was just
can you show that ban by the way so
everybody can see it show that article
from abc news biden to announce ban
on russian oil imports okay uh that's
not eu that's not anybody else that's
just us meanwhile
uh putin is not slowing down
meanwhile a lot of stuff that was said
about ukraine and russia and the
relationships people are being more
educated about what really is going on
you know a lot of times you hear about
a crisis or or a war or challenge that's
taking place we overreact and then you
kind of see there's a different side to
the story and you realize okay why were
you pushing for them to be part of nato
where they said don't do it if they're
you're trying to produce this ally
you're going up against them do you
really want the relationship and then at
the same time putin
being the kind of guy that
you know you know certainly guys you get
into a fight with and he says
if you say something i'll knock your ass
out okay nine out of ten times it's what
it's just a threat but there's that one
guy
that if you say something he will knock
you out putin's part of that community
so you have to be very careful how
you're dealing with that guy maybe you
have a different opinion we'll talk
about that as well oh no i have a
different opinion he's really he is he
he's he is who he really is and what's
what's interesting is yesterday i'm
driving with dylan and we're coming here
because he's this is their week out
dylan what's your yesterday tico's
today and dylan says so daddy uh did
ukraine uh uh uh uh uh no did did putin
already start the nuclear war i said why
this is what dylan's said i said how do
you know about this he says oh that's
all everybody's talking about all my
friends
this gets eight years old wow
did putin already start the nuclear war
i'm like not yet buddy let's just hope
it doesn't happen because the domino
effect will be pretty ugly so anyways
having said that johnny
for the few people that don't know your
background can you take a quick minute
and tell everybody your background
my background your background admit it
yes
try to do it in a minute i mean you love
everybody you have you matter of fact
how about i do it for you here's what
i'm gonna do okay here's what i'm gonna
do when you and i did the the the show
together what was it three years from
three that was three years ago i can't
even believe it's three years that's the
last time you guys saw each other sat in
the same room oh we've spoken i don't
know how i talk to them all wait we yeah
correspond electronically but in person
the person is three years ago in my
living room in new york how good does he
look he looks better today than he was
three years ago i'm not even kidding
with you first thing i said is i can't
believe how you look yeah he looks
better today than the three if you go
look at the podcast he looks better
today than three years probably what's
your secret johnny here we go i'm doing
stem cells man oh really doing stem
cells i'm part of an experiment my
second experiment my first was 1949 with
jonas salt for the salt vaccine for
polio and then i got involved in this
in a very strange way
i was rushed to new york presbyterian
about 12 years ago
and
for six
gunshots and hold on what do you mean
you were i was shot six times at close
range
anyway
a friend
a friend of the family shot you okay and
when they went in to do it
they saw that my left side of my body
was smaller than my right side not
realizing my my five years were polio
and the doctors that were operating on
me
realized i'm a great candidate
for
having this stem cell how old were you
at the time
um
71 so no no 69 69 years old yeah i'll be
i'll be 80 this so what year was that
the first time you did it
did you hear what he just said folks
he'll be 80 this december 80. hey man
back to you let me get something
do you send me by the way show that
david can you show that to see what he
looks like there versus what he looks
like today
just show that picture
you look better today than you did in
that picture okay tanner healthier still
bling-bling and that's that's not that
he's always
all this has a meaning yeah everything
here everything i wear
is a meaning it's not i just don't go to
the store so i like that buy it this is
a pin from my grandfather knights of
malta the vatican
i mean all this stuff means something
what's the most meaningful piece of
jewelry you're rocking uh john paul
who's now a saint he gave me
the crest that's covered right now
because of solidarity to ukraine covered
it with a black ribbon but he gave me
that in 1948.
you're talking about the pope pope john
paul who's now a saint yeah which and my
little kids my grandkids say to me papa
you're the only guy we know you really
know is saying you knew him
because they all had pictures yeah 1948.
i was 48. oh you were 48. okay you were
40 when he gave it to him you met him
over there yeah was he the vatican
i was there for the i knew three popes
two pride of him the one that had the
short run and then they inaugurated him
and i was part of that i was very good
friends with uh bishop masinkas
during the vatican and the man the
vatican bank and
we were doing a lot of business out of
vegas for about 20 years with him
johnny
for people who don't know for people who
don't know
you were where you you were you dated
obviously a lot a lot of big names but
dionne you you and uh the uh uh dionne
were together for how long 10 years i
was a manager of 15 years i can't even
say why i did that but no no we were we
weren't uh
that's a very
touchy situation for you but but the
point but you ran one of the biggest
clubs in vegas oh my god i clubs yeah
well i actually that was my second club
my first club was at tiffany's which i
had elvis presley open at the tropicana
hotel and that was
actually right after i did the godfather
elvis opened for you yeah open no open
the club for me stayed the whole weekend
thursday friday and saturday
by the way did you watch his uh did you
watch his uh
movie that's coming out did you see the
trailer no have you seen it yet or no no
can we show a trailer i don't know if we
can show a trailer anyways it's not
alone okay we're not going to show the
trailer but you were going to read his
uh bio but i tell you you know going
going off of elvis so
uh uh i i i
mario comes over sunday night
and
he has watched this trailer that we
can't show mario can verify this he said
he's watched it a hundred times okay
because mario grew up being an elvis guy
so he tells me pat you got to watch uh
elvis presley's last performance
unchained melody
he you can tell when elvis performs he's
not doing well he performs unchained
melody
[Music]
unchained melody
goldberg he performs it saying this
song's coming out in two weeks
the song comes out he dies a couple
weeks later okay elvis to to have him
open up at your club what elvis story do
you have tell us an elvis i have so many
give us your best best sellers i mean
first of all
elvis who was working for a friend of
mine called kirk cocorian who opened the
international hotel gm yeah and is very
familiar
started as a pilot the way he
and how he made his money and
you know he was also another guy that
always dated beautiful women
and there are a lot of movie stars the
mob
the ma he flew a lot of those guys back
and forth from la to vegas
while they were going through building
up vegas
and then the airline business and all
that stuff yeah
really no more so
let's tell us some stories of elvis and
then maybe kurt well elvis elvis i met
because of kurt
the idea when he opened the fourth of
july
i forgot what year that was barbara
streisand did two weeks
they did two shows a night at that time
eight o'clock in midnight this is the
sixties what we're giving in the
seventies i think early 70s yeah
international hotel
is he the facts guy yeah hey fax guy
what are you doing over there sleeping
on the job
international hotel kirkachorian opened
on 4th of july 1976.
international hotel 1976.
just put that but continue we're
listening continue so anyway
i got to know him because you know he
said how come everybody knows you know i
had bentleys with chinese chick show for
senior year he liked all that stuff but
i knew his doctor
elias got him
and they used to dr feel good and anyway
so uh we got to be friends and he
invited me to hang out with him and we
used to fly to san francisco you ain't
gonna believe this two or three this is
kirk or korean or elvis elvis straight
out we want to talk about elvis right
yeah
so you fly to san francisco fly to san
francisco
and have peanut butter
bananas
and bacon sandwiches
i should why not we could add the chef
to it no no no this is the best we'd go
i'd go i went once i said you don't want
it plus eating this [ __ ] i'll forget
about it i come with six o'clock in the
morning i was like forget it but one
night we come back early
and we're watching the western
and when he got mustered out of the
service they gave him two plated gold
cup 45s and he always has him around
we're watching a western he gets into it
his crew is on one side i have a couple
of guys with me on my side
and they turn over the couches and
they're shooting above the tv like
they're fighting with the guys on the tv
bank guard is sweet 3 thousands it's the
penthouse of of the international hotel
because it was if there was people
upstairs with 45s they'd be dead in
their beds
shot up the whole room but he didn't
realize we all carry because in vegas
everybody carried guns so not everybody
in the 70s or 60s in the 60s okay got it
no 70s okay it was the 70s
do you get the date
yes so uh corey and hired barbara
streisand and elvis presley for the
opening in uh 76. i told you
seven i got a good one for an old man
man
forget about it yeah no but so i got
friendly with them so i opened my club
called tiffany's inside the tropicana
hotel because frank costello
nobody realizing joe kennedy owned that
behind the scenes
so i had nothing to do so i opened a
club only three days a week
only six hours a day i opened at
midnight to six in the morning after
hours after hours
and
had tables in there did everything i
made more money in those 16 hours and i
love it i don't want to be in vegas on
monday tuesday wednesdays nobody's there
so i go to la palm beach or whatever
and he came he said i'll open it because
he after his show
one 130 he'd come and hang out there all
morning
but and we were on the radio dispatchers
to everybody so you got a cab and say i
want to go here they said oh no you got
to go to elvis is over there and then
sammy came everybody's standing and out
there it was jammed and put the club on
the map sammy davis yeah yeah
i called the tiffany's and i put the
tiffany gates like bars
on the front with tiffany guards like
your jewelry store and all the coffee
tables were jewelry counters with fake
jewelry in it it was a great idea
and you can only buy a liquor the food
we gave away because all the restaurants
were closing and they had a core kitchen
i said what are you going to do with
this food
you know we'll give it to that i said
hold it
sell it back to me
or you're going to throw away anyway
i'll sign off on it and you can write
the whole thing off
so we did everything in miniature
sandwiches so these little hot
waitresses to come by with steak
sandwiches in this sandwich it was awful
leftovers from the other one wow but and
everything was seven dollars then which
was a lot of money then
and if you wanted a coke with seven
dollars glass of water with seven
dollars everything everything what was
the significance of seven dollars which
is i like that number
lucky number seven yeah and this is
76 elvis was on his decline this was not
the good looking stud elvis right
well he really wasn't
let me tell you elvis in his grave is
still
important to look at
no doubt no no he was you know sort of
shout out to one thing like you i know
you guys are loyal my guy's around me i
got kids around me all my life
i still blame the memphis mafia for his
death
they had all the prescription drug
they would give him the drugs they'll go
get their prescriptions and gave it to
him
i mean this guy was so screwed up if you
see your best friend
going down
what do you do you stop him sit him down
and straighten him out
he should have lived a great life this
guy
i mean he died a terrible death i mean
you know he died all right
let's just use it clean he died of
constipation
right
well all the drugs in the system are you
going to get it out what was the show he
said heart disease his body closed down
he had like
40 pounds
in them or waste
when they did the autopsy you know what
age you died
you know what age you died
42 years old yeah well mom
mm-hmm
42. no no crazy is to do i mean that's
young
what kind of drugs was elvis doing
everything everything pills cocaine
heroin what i don't know that
i don't think i don't know if it was
really i think it was all prescription i
don't know yeah i never saw him do i saw
him do i'd smack him i don't like
anybody doing drugs in front of me
especially me getting involved they
would love to lock me up for something
they've been trying for 70 years but
vegas in the 60s 70s i mean it's
partying it's out of control what was
the
the drug scene like back then i don't
know i don't know i never got involved
in that just drinking i never gotten
well i i drank yeah but i never did
drugs never got involved i could have
made a lot of money on drugs because i'd
uh international courier's license i was
traveling the world with millions of
dollars all the time
but and they asked me you know you could
take this out for us
so johnny let me let me let me kind of
do this with you here because
your stories if you when you and i sat
and i said i said johnny if if 10 of the
stories you're telling me is true you
live the ridiculous life let me kind of
remind the audience who's maybe hasn't
seen or heard all the stories they're
here for the first time let me kind of
share some of the stories here with them
so so here's what we got you one of them
you
you
claim you lost your virginity to marilyn
monroe at 15. 15 and a half yeah 15 and
a half and you spent three days with her
well i went to look after her i want to
set this stage straight
she was staying at the at the um
walled up astoria as a guest to mr
costello who basically took me under his
wing at 12 years old so i was already
working for him for three and a half
years he was going deep-sea fishing
people don't realize he loved to fish
with tony acado the boss of the alpha to
chicago
so he said we have a guest at the hotel
this weekend go i knew the sweets they
kept
and
i went up there
but what he didn't realize
because when i got caught
on the streets
at fort at 15
a tune officer saw me in front of
lindy's and he said what are you doing
on the street that's what you're talking
about because he had a brown uniform i
said who knows this guy i knew he was in
a cop he's on my tune officer i said
what do you do
he's i'm catching kids like you why
aren't you in school i said what are you
talking about i don't go to school i
have like 5 000 in my pocket already
because i'm running stuff for him
so you got to go to school so he gives
me a ticket and i was on the way
to to to chores it was one of my stops
everybody was there every day late
afternoon joe dimaggio jackie gleason
because he was doing the show from the
cbs right there
and i walk in with the ticket
and costello says to me how did you get
a ticket walking too fast what's this
and you looked at it and he says it's a
true officer
he's how old are you i said 15.
he said well you got to go to school in
new york state until you're 16. i said i
don't want to go to school so he put me
in wilford academy he had dressing
school which was on my route
so he's just stopped by sign in until
six months in december you'll be sixteen
and forget about it
so i go in there
it's nine o'clock in the morning
twenty thirty gorgeous little girls
so i was on the way to meet him and
eleven o'clock was already dressed so i
used to go there a day or two i mean an
hour or two every day
and mark sinclair and kenneth
came in biggest hairdressers in new york
looking for shampoo boys and i was a
good-looking guy when i was
dressed
not like these other kids because i was
going to meet him
and they picked me
the fourth had a hair at lily dashes on
56th and park was milo monroe's
they and it was not like we go to a
salon here and as well lined up sinks
private rooms
literally that [ __ ] was a haberdasher
two-story building kenneth was the
featured uh hairdresser and mark
sinclair was a colorist
and i didn't i thought when they said
they were partners they owned the
business they were partners and like we
know them today partners are very open
so long story short the fourth head of
hair i go in
and it's melon monroe
and she's already in you know shampoo
base look at this and i don't even know
how long i was looking at her
and she's is someone here i said excuse
me
yes i'm sorry and they give you a card
nobody's name's on it you know what the
shampoo the rinse that you gotta they
teach you to test the water and put it
on the inside of her wrist she has to
okay the water
now nobody knows a lot of times in the
winter especially i used to go to
new york paramount obviously in
paramount still in my world for now the
last 50 years
they used to be open 24 hours a day
i saw some like it hot
maybe 50 times and i was masturbating up
in in the balcony at 15.
she's singing i want to make love to you
in this sheer dress in the film
now i'm starting to massage hershey you
want the strongest massage yeah that's
what she is they have great pictures
but anyway i'm misogynist she starts
moaning
like you know
now we know the configuration of a
shampoo basin so my three-piece sets on
her shoulders
[Laughter]
and as i'm misogyna
i get an erection
now i don't know why and you're 15 at
the time
who wouldn't 15. looking at this in a
row but i'm not trying to look into it
i'm visualizing all kinds of things but
now
what no i had a towel dry a hand i'm
drying it yeah like a hair was going to
wear out because i'm thinking how am i
going to walk from here to the station i
got this teepee in my hands
how am i going to walk out there
everybody we look at them especially
these you know these guys that uh had
their vision on me anyway classic
and then she started requesting me
always a big tipper too i kept
and i not that i needed mike because i
was making good money with costello but
i kept one check she gave me for fifty
dollars i can't even tell you what it's
worth today you have it till today hello
you still have a check signed by marilyn
monroe i hear your pillowcase that she
kissed
signed by monroe
and
i'm writing my second book which will be
out there this christmas which is ironic
that you said come on
because the last time my book came out
three years ago is still a bestseller
hollywood godfather my life in the movie
and the mom
and
now
what nobody realized when the last
weekend i spent with a cal neva
when she went crazy on bobby kennedy and
we found out all kinds of news we didn't
want to know we knew they were going to
kill her and she was dead five days
later
i called from cal never because her and
i had a cat together
merlin monroe you know in her apartment
but i knew marilyn you know she
some she disappeared for a week you
don't know where she went so i had this
lady taking care of the cat
so i called her i said do me a favor
marilyn's coming home because joe
dimaggio he called cal never
and he asked sinatra it's what's going
on she wants me to come and get his mind
your own business don't come here and he
was in san francisco
and he didn't come if he came she'd
probably still be alive well she'd be
100 today but
but he could have saved the life he did
should be 100 today
101 101 but johnny follow-up question i
mean we're talking about marilyn monroe
here so you're the shampoo boy good
looking guy suited up you got a tp in
your pants you're hanging out how does
it transition to your 15 and a half
almost 16 to actually having sex losing
your virginity
this
two or three women i never had sex with
i made love to
one of them grace kelly her there's
certain people you hold the royal grace
kelly by the way i don't know if you
caught that right in there yeah pull up
a picture of grace kelly if you don't
mind
if you don't mind walk us through the
white house
costello
a guest in the hotel i don't know who's
up there
so he's don't go up before noon so i go
knock on the door
that's an amazing woman yeah
she used to stay at the barbers on on
well you know where i live she lived on
63rd and lexington the barbers on was a
hotel just for women her family were in
mason business in philadelphia they sent
her the ad for finishing school you're
talking about grace kelly yeah okay
heart audrey hepburn all of that
costello used to say go get flowers for
the table i knew where i had to go he
gave me money i go upstairs get the
money take a cab i never took the cab i
walked i kept the money i took the care
back but i picked these girls up so i
got to know them for two or three years
while they were finishing school before
she became a princess that's how crazy
this is but how big was maryland but at
the at this time huge so you go up to
her
the biggest movie in the world
they send you up to her hotel room
i knock on the door she opens it at
terry cloth row he says johnny what are
you doing here i said well mr c told me
to look in on you she knew you by now
for sure well i was a shampoo boy hello
so i was already shampoo and hair for
three or four months
so i come in she's i just ordered
breakfast come in i had room service i
didn't even know what room service was
you know i was i never was in the rooms
i was outside them she had all these
carts i said i already had breakfast
i said i'm just supposed to check on it
you saw sit down i said mr seal get mad
do you need
johnny sit down so i sat down she had
the calista champagne i started laughing
i said i'm 15. she oh she knew how old
you were
yeah well you could tell
i told i was 15.
i can't drink i don't have to be 18 a
drink in new york
she gives me a glass of champagne so i'm
getting a buzz
so i'm going to take a bath i swear
listen i'll be downstairs just call
downstairs they all know the kid because
that was my name in the hotel
just tell them whatever you want no no
come with me she takes me by the hand in
the bathroom she turns the water on
and she sits down she's brush out my
hair you always you know from the salon
i did it anyway
so she lowers the robe and i'm saying
that i'm not gonna get in trouble yet
today forget about
she's i mean
today she's exotic woman
not then voluptuous voluptuous
what's the word
yeah thick and they were up and down up
and down weight especially up
so now i'm brushing out here
she walks over to the tub shops off the
water and she drops her rope she got
nothing
she's getting in the tub with me i said
you're gonna get me killed so who's
gonna know
so now i couldn't get my clothes off
fast enough
and i get in the other side the bottom
of the back of the tub with huh adam you
need a break or are you good yeah guys
i'm gonna
[Music]
monroe here what are we talking about no
so now what happens is
that was a saturday afternoon
out of respect that was a saturday
afternoon i left monday morning
so that whole weekend you're just
staying there it's late they're willing
and you're saying you made love not sex
that's right who was the third person he
said grace kelly marilyn monroe number
three was i can't imagine the other one
oh really royalty
really the third one you can't mention
so royalty above grace kelly yeah
believe it i heard you had a
conversation with brando
and he says i don't believe you straight
up he called you out he goes i don't
believe that you had sex with marilyn
monroe
and he said he says tell me something
that nobody would know
tony curtis yeah all of us
sinatra
she
that's that's what's
she's so naive
that's all she thought she can give you
is our body can i make you happy
she didn't even think of it that way
and if you were with her there's she has
a scar
just where her leg joins her cleavage
unless you whether you never see that so
that's the if you're really with marilyn
yeah where's the scar it's down here
okay the crease gotcha
how big is the scar
not that not that big but but it's
possible oh no it's not so if you've
been with maryland you made love with
marilyn you're gonna notice this guy
yeah can i read these other stories i
don't know
i know you are let me just you know
maybe this is a good uh sauce cast you
know maybe it's more sauce cats
go ahead yes all right so let me read
these stories all right
so you have to know
each of these stories one is sounds more
crazy than the other one but let me kind
of go through number one lost your
virginity at 15 to marilyn monroe people
say that's crazy number two you killed a
pedophile
at the hospital at 11. number three mob
kill jfk a lot of people say that mob
killed marilyn monroe you've said that
before pablo escobar intended to kill
you
and your family but he lets you live in
exchange for reenacting
a scene from the godfather
well not for that he found out why john
gotti lied to him see john and john
gotti arranged for me to get down there
what happened
one of his guys came into my club in
vegas state street a pablo's pablo's
guys lorenzo morales and he broke a
cristal bottle and stuck it in his
girlfriend's face in my club
i that's how i killed that guy i went to
in self-defense
to that to help her that's written about
that's that's how it's in the paper yeah
yeah he cut you apparently he slipped me
you see those stitches 81 stitches man
because i was agile enough he went from
my neck and i went this way i didn't
know he had the bottle yet
so it wasn't until
two days later i got out of the hospital
laura mannist the girl he stabbed thank
god he missed her eye
but i put three right between his
forehead that night in front of 150. you
didn't do time for that though you
didn't you were self-defense yeah and i
let everybody know i said because i told
them you hear these sirens they're
coming for you i i never knew if they
were mobbed up who they were i said so
you had no idea who he was i have no
idea i got you so later on you find out
he's linked to pablo lorenzo morales
it was known they were watching him so
the dea came to see me he said johnny
you know where that guy was no
he was one of the top guys in america
for pablo escobar
hello so now i go and they put it they
put it on uh entertainment tonight i
think was the first time the show was on
and you know a love triangle and this
there was no love triangle they had it
all wrong
and they you know
and i had i got serious phone calls
thought maybe i was getting involved
with drugs
i said no i didn't even know the guy
she came to her defense
in your club right but he was a
mariolito
and what they do
any one his brother was the guy was
coming after me they come to defend
but they'll kill your pets your
neighbors
everybody and leave you last
so i go see john gotti who never liked
me really anyway but i knew
some for some reason that he was dealing
with all of them
and he arranged for me to go there
he figured this i'll never come back
you're going there i said yeah i should
at the time i had one daughter i have
two now and i knew that he had a
daughter and they were going to come my
daughter
says i gotta straighten this out he got
the story wrong
and he's you're gonna go there i said
yeah to wear medellin yeah
that's where i went
the only comfort i had was gonna meet
him in a church
so i met him in a church and i'm walking
down the aisle i thought he was there by
himself in an altar up in the front
as i'm walking the pews as i pass them
are creaking and guys are sitting up the
church was loaded with his guys
i mean i don't even why i would think
he'd be there by himself
and that and then he said you johnny
russo i said yeah bang he hit me and
that was it he didn't hit me but
somebody from behind and i woke up in
the cell that he created in that prison
that he built yeah i was three floors
down with body bags around me the stinch
was ridiculous
and
then i don't know how many hours later
there's a guy clean dressed not in
fatigues i'm sitting in a chair shackled
nude in a chair
and in his hand
he had the making of the godfather
i mean this movie is so crazy in my life
and he said why don't you tell me you
were calling when the god well that's my
favorite movie is clean him up and bring
him up to the house
so hours later i'm sitting at his dining
room table he's sitting at one arm at
the other end
and he said why did you come here that's
why i did my homework
you have a daughter my age of my
daughter geo and someone's going to kill
her what would you do
and he got up
he walked over and hugged me and he says
there's very few men like you that would
come here
he's i'll straighten this out
and i thank god i thought he was dead
he's just do me a favor i said anything
you want you want me to cut the grass
wash your car i was kidding now because
i don't get to get out of there
he said i want to do the scene in the
godfather as a what scene
is the closing scene when michael comes
to see you
i said okay
you want me to write as no no i know the
whole scene
as you know the whole scene is yeah he's
come up sit up here where he was sitting
because it was closest to the door he
gets up
and now he had henchmen in there around
him anyway and he walks into me
and i'm sitting where he was sitting he
says
carlo
you gotta answer for santini
today i straightened out all family
business
he did the whole scene and does he speak
perfect english is it uh
no but he had the he had the lines right
but so he spoke english oh yeah escobar
oh yeah
and so now you're doing a scene from the
godfather with
pablo escobar and you're playing you
know how hard this is to believe
i don't know do you know like
do you
uh you unders interviewed the guys that
killed pablo if if you would have killed
pablo and pablo he was who to pablo
lorenzo was who
lorenzo was his uh one of his top
leaders
for him to
let you go
and let you live if you did do that
johnny that is that has got to be it's
not yeah take if that in a volcano
that's crazy
because the dea proved it they knew i
was there because when i got when i
landed in florida
when he let me go yeah they boarded the
plane like in a movie
and the hostess said nobody get up
somebody has to come on and they came on
the plane there's where's johnny russo i
raised my hand i still had the bandages
on from my neck
they took me off the plane i'm on a
plane going to washington from florida
on their plane nobody's talking to me
so now i got to go to the bathroom they
had me handcuffed 3 500 feet here what
are we doing handcuffs on so i said can
you take yourself i got to go to the
bathroom so i go to the bathroom and i
come out one of the dea agents standing
near the door says to me
you were calling the godfather right i
said yeah
so he comes out they must have had a bet
unbeknownst to me so that got a little
light
on the plane now they were not like
they said what were you doing with pablo
escobar
i said and they didn't know this talking
about the government don't know what the
states are doing
i said well i killed his guy you did
what i said i killed this guy saturday
night in my club so they went on
get this information
and i did
so now i just admitted i killed this guy
i'm walking out of there they thought i
was the new guy
what do you mean the new guy
connection for drugs they saw me with
they saw me with gotti in new york they
watch everything
they see me down there for two days and
i'm walking out
and then they prove that you know
and then i was in washington maybe a
couple of hours they checked everything
out everything was proven they said you
can go i swear me go i'm in washington
well yeah
i said i'm going to vegas
we don't
provide transportation i had to get my
own flight to go back to where i was
going
no but i mean they knew
they have records of it
i mean there's there's probably a crazy
story i mean here's a robbing 86 million
dollars in three hours from six banks
okay you got the shot of iran out of the
country before his regime fell
talking about russian vladimir putin
having special intel that putin had
exiled stephen seagal to siberia that's
right you recorded meeting saddam
hussein when he was tasked with dropping
money off to him in a weapons deal and
you sat in his throne you know
the current status of the mob and said
that the organizations are rebuilding
and adapting
to the times especially in new york
and sicily right the jaja gavor you guys
went on a date and then she ended up
setting you up with a sex with another
woman okay i believe that that's that
bruce you had the the threesomes with
who liza uh manelli after
both took a liking to the some vegas
showgirl oh no bear touching vegas is
what
she was the star of bad touch of egg she
was the girl was yeah and liza was the
riviera hotel i remember that vividly we
went over to stardust hotel i was always
over here did you make a love or was it
more like always insane no we didn't
make love we didn't make love i got you
it wasn't one of the three
you know you were the first person are
you ready for this yeah i still remember
a lady's name emilia escavall
that's who emelita escobar was the
dancer in bad touch in vegas she came
out of this out of the ceiling
in a bodysuit like a snake coming down
and we'll lead an eskimo and and liza
and i were sitting there we both look at
her and we said
we got to have a
but she said and i said that to her and
we took her up to the bridal sweet i
always had the bridal suite well nick
niddy just so your audience knows nick
niddy
and i were partners
we were couriers
taking money from vegas
to the vatican we used to go every other
week
we had licenses we weren't doing
anything illegal and the story you
talked about
about the shah yeah your parents
indirectly were involved with that and
we talked about that while we were hello
we were in uh how's that yeah when we
spoke about this in uh in uh what do you
call it new york what do you mean your
parents parents dad not not mom more on
the dad's side yeah papa yeah huh so pat
you've interviewed johnny yeah this is
the second time you've spoken multiple
people you've spoken so yeah the names
that are being just flung around here
elvis
marilyn monroe the freaking pope pablo
escobar liza minnelli here you know jfk
he keeps saying if
and just just for clarity if anybody
writes anything and anybody that is
educated enough
a book publisher that's anything you say
in a book or they exclude it
because they don't want to get sued
like mcmullen books out of london wrote
published my book through saint martin's
press again hollywood godfather all
these stories are in that book so
certain people
that he even knows questioned it they
questioned it on air they wanted to talk
to me i'm not going to
first you understand why people believe
think that this is absolutely insane
i hit the ground at 12 years old with a
guy called frank costello most people
are going to school until 21 22 years of
age
i'm on the streets with this guy flying
everywhere
i was with you know
senator john f kennedy for the first two
years since 59 to 60 until he won the
nomination to become president i mean
how come i got all that because costello
wouldn't go
i got the tickets i went i went
everywhere but he afforded me these
luxuries that most people would never
have and who was who was he at the time
in the mob at this point frank costello
at that time was running the geneves
family while vito was in prison when he
came out and he wanted his family back
chin
chinchigante chinjaganti was his first
contract to kill him which i still don't
believe that that was in a setup because
chin and frank were in the elevator in
his building
and shot him in the head
in an elevator and he missed
and four days later chin and him haven't
dinner together
because frank wanted he didn't want this
no more
that's when him and costello
and other people
created the syndicate
and took over everything
people i live in frank costello's
apartment in new york
during prohibition him and joe kennedy
made 30 million dollars each in the 30s
the money they amassed during
prohibition started buying buildings
they're building live living they own
they own two wall street that's the sky
kennedy and castello yeah they own the
tropical irish and the italians hello
well the irish of course the prohibition
of law
i mean by the way a few things that
for for the level of skepticism you know
everybody's got a healthy level of
skepticism about everything everybody
that's their job that's what that's what
people are you do that i do that we
everybody does that naturally but but a
few things uh
that opens the door to opportunities
right think about what businesses opens
the door to meet crazy people right one
if you are the concierge of the best
hotel in the world i'm sorry
you probably have the right connections
right if you run the hottest club
in a city for a span of five years my
friends of mine that rank club you have
a lot of friends that rank clubs you
know everybody who's who because they
come and don't worry gotcha bottles
somewhere and then you get hey
afterwards come to our house that is
very natural that happens in that in the
gym business crazy thing about gym
business you meet everybody and anybody
media the other day i watched the
documentary of uh the the forbes malcolm
forbes right and a very old documentary
i watch you know who malcolm forbes was
best friends with for decades his best
friend was elizabeth taylor and they
used to do a bunch of different things
together he put a party together for his
70th birthday party flew everybody out
on a private jet 700 guests
and at his birthday party spent two and
a half million dollars just on private
jets to come to the party everybody's
gift to attend his birthday party was a
rolex watch custom rolex watch he gave
700 guests a customized rolex watch to
his guests now who's over there
kissinger presidents billionaires
celebrities so so there are certain
industries that you get now obviously on
the mob side if you are nobody knows i
mean it's not like people don't know
for a fact but if you're in
connected with costello and if you know
costello costello is with ben seagull
meyer lansky and lucky i mean that's
like the
founders not like i don't know if i
would say founders but they would be
what they created the
they created the the five family uh what
do you call it the chair and lucky sat
on the chair so you're talking about the
guys that brought us so if you're with
frank costello and you know the story of
frank costello frank costello was a guy
that had politicians had connections
with a lot of different people he
he was the biz dev guy he was the guy
behind closed doors that knew how to
move everybody right that's kind of how
i was so
in those types of situations
you're going to meet him now is it going
to get you to hook up with marilyn
monroe 15 and a half and you know go
grace kelly and all that i don't know
about that stuff but i mean if you did
salutations the one thing i will tell
you though uh uh uh with with gianni
first of all
you're you're way
way too handsome naturally
and then
you're
79 i i asked them we had one of our
girls here and i said you know
johnny i bet you used to be you know
great with the ladies i still am you
know the whole thing you were talking
about uh during covet you know how oh
yeah
you were taken care of so looks helps a
lot here's a crazy thing about people
that don't know this
your first movie you ever did it's not
like your fifth movie tenth movie it's
not like you got a resume of coming from
the best you know
school for acting or anything
the first movie you ever did was
godfather one all right
can you tell i mean you've been in
seabiscuit you've done a few different
things that you've been in oh after that
yeah after that but
a person doesn't just get casted for
potentially the greatest movie of all
time how did that for people that don't
know what's the story behind that and
you know what's so funny about that
because even that was in question and
there's a new a new tv series coming out
called the offer
by paramount will be out next month
and they don't even mention how i got
the part which makes no sense because
every actor
like you said already had a resume i
mean pacino only did one movie but it
was panicking needle park
and they wanted them
and and coppola was the only one who
wanted them but long story short
there's a new book out and i can't
believe i'm in this book i'm in 11 books
right now but james patterson being a
james patterson book
called the defense attorney it's out
right now
on page 70 and 71
it tells you how i got the pawn the
godfather tells you in that book
and who gave it to me and who told bobby
evans stanley jaffe
and everybody said oh that didn't happen
again that book was vetted
this was barry schlotnik
who was a young attorney for
italian defamation league
fiction or non-fiction it's a
non-fiction book
notes your biography biobiography i got
you i got it
and not written by regular guys so no
yeah so you're saying so the people that
were involved
kennedy no the people who got me the
part exactly the people that were being
pushed apart see i i got lured in they
had an ad in in l.a times
that italians would be italians jewish
doctors would be jewish doctors the book
was already its third print the
godfather was huge
and my ego i always wanted to be an
actor i already had money i didn't need
to be i don't care if i i just wanted to
be in it
so i
shot a test michael sonny and carlo
got some people betty mccart who was al
rudy's private secretary
at paramount founder who she knew i need
to have a drive on because i want to
just deliver this
i do everything in a grand way at the
time i had a 65 bentley with a chinese
chick chauffeur 65 bentley and i got the
cover
of a aeroflex 16 millimeter box that i
shot my three scenes on
and special delivery for al ruddy and
she could only deliver to him betty
mccott got the drive on
so she pulls up everybody's got to drive
who's this chinese chick with this car
the car was insane
i had a coco bentley coco brown they
didn't have coffee 65 bentley let's see
that well that ain't me that's it
yeah but anyway
so this car pulls up
what's this about
it was my screen test
so they wrote me a nice letter scene i
know you went to extremes
and we are not yeah i mean but mine was
gold-plated everything grilled
everything i got pictures of it but
the interesting thing is so when i got
it in my head now i said wait a minute i
want i told everybody i'm going to be in
this movie
so now i find out that joe columbo is
picketing the fbi building in new york
because joe colombo jr got arrested so
he's sane because of the godfather
everybody thinks we're gangsters and he
created the anti-defamation league he
hired this jewish attorney barry slanek
brilliant guy still alive he moved down
here
and
i meet with him and i knew it was about
money i fly in i said joe
we can make a lot of money because you
notice i said we
i said we can make a lot of money with
this mortgage how are we going to make
any money
i said
why don't we have barry take a meeting
at gulf and western building that's now
the trump plaza
and sit with them what you don't like in
the book if they take it out give them
permission to shoot because they were
picketing everything and they were going
to cancel the movie
and i wanted this movie
i said and we can make a little maze how
are we going to make the money i said
you're if you let them shoot you you're
going to ask with the world premiere in
every major city the night before and
we'll sell tickets for 200 300
have black tie event for every italian
league we give a little check to them we
keep the rest of the money
is you could do this i swear your
permission i don't know if i could do it
i said but if i go up there
can i arrange your meeting you sit and
he looks at barry's what do you think
barry's was a good idea
so i went up
i walked to madison he ever knew their
office up central parks out went up my
weight in the elevator
downstairs i'm seeing them all coming in
bobby evans stanley jaffe alrudy
and i go over to them i said listen you
got a problem in new york we don't have
no problem anymore i said i could
straighten it out they all looked at
each other you could straighten it out i
see i just slept joe columbo
ready said you just left who i said joe
colombo that's the guy's model in there
right
he said yeah he's right down here now i
don't know if he went upstairs to call
the fbi because they already robbed
equipment on them i'm sitting there they
send this girl down no naomi cherry
the secretary to stanley jaffe this is
52 years ago they sent this girl down i
met her once i still know her name
naomi jaffe no me naomi cherry cherry
stanley jaffe was the president that was
his secretary
they come she comes against me i go up
there all sitting there
like this
i stand in there
i said
i just talked to barry slotnick and joe
they'd like to sit down and get
distrained out
they said will he come here i said come
here come here
will you come here tomorrow ten o'clock
i said you tell us when
so
so now i go now this is the meeting's on
10 o'clock tomorrow i said
let's do something though i said i'm
only suggesting you can't tell this guy
who's the boss he took over the columbo
family
after they killed pavachis
because pavacci was attempting to kill
carlo gambino after you know that it was
a big gang war going on
so he's the youngest boss ever
joe
so we go up there i should get butter as
to chico to come with us a couple of
heavies
because i want to have that appearance
the eternity you and i and
so we get up there and they iron
everything out and
they gave them the script barry's going
to read it mark it up over the weekend
and
so they're all shaking hands and i go
joe i i don't get up they all got up i
said sure what about me
he said oh yeah yeah what about my boy
so right hollywood [ __ ]
oh don't worry we're going to go apart i
said wait a minute i said joe tell him
to sit down he goes like this
he all set up
mr president
of paramount bobby evans although they
all sit down
and i said what do you mean a part
i said i arranged this
so this is going to be news to even your
audience and maybe you guys i said who's
playing michael
that said james kahn michael
who's playing sonny call mine kiriti
because he's a big guy in a play called
the demand for la mancha
i said who's playing carlo they said we
didn't get to that yet i said joe i want
to play carlo
this is in james patterson's book page
1771
they they write the whole thing
he says he's playing carlo
they all looked at each other he says
he's playing carlo
that's how he got the ball
forget the audition the money i spent
and it changed my life
crazy the story was just done on it and
they said uh
uh by the guardian
uh
this thing of ours why does the
godfather still ring true 50 years on
right and this is if you want to go to
this page to adam so uh
uh uh there there are the endless mob
movies of course but more important than
uh mere weight of numbers is the scale
of influence extended by just one
dynasty like a remarried parent the
godfather has
the original offspring two and three
then it has more good fellas the
sopranos in the course of the first film
corleone's tell
uh pacino uh pacino's michael he had
hoped his son would become a politician
instead politics became the godfather
where the rule we are ruled by men who
do
impressions of the dawn and kissing the
rain crosses anyways this movie went
from being a regular thing that came out
to now i mean it's crazy it's
presidents this is their favorite movie
politicians favorite movies i call it
every favorite movie celebrities
favorite movies it's amazing yes
like you mentioned saddam hussein yeah
he had the scene queued up but he had a
big tv when i went through that he had
like crazy stories it's crazy saddam
hussein
is watching the godfather with you no i
didn't watch him he had the scene up i
didn't watch a movie with him i went to
his no he was doing an arms deal with
nadine khashoggi and i brought the money
over that's how i went there he didn't
open his doors for me i was there for a
reason will you spend one-on-one time
with him no no just and hello goodbye
and was there about an hour did you see
what it says about here with the
capitalism about the godfather do you
read that part which part is that
which is capitalism where are you okay
invisible power thrives elsewhere
because
another literal subject of the godfather
is capitalism coppola said it was his
biggest theme uh there omerta remains
the watch ward how many of us could
identify the head of the companies whose
products we buy how much corporate
uh uh skull uh scala
duggary remains out of sight and if the
first lesson of the godfathers trust no
one the second is that each generation
ends up living the life of the one
before so it has proved
50 years after don carleone the mafia is
a husk america itself is coming undone
but the bright right of the godfather
keeps being
handed down now as then our world is
strictly business
guardian article march 4th what's the
the the
lineage of capitalism with the godfather
what are they basically trying to say
right there with the omarta
what would you say to that well i'll
tell you right now i i have a company
that i'm involved with called mj
licensing company
we own an exclusive license
for foods liquor first ride refusal
worldwide
we have seven liquors approved i don't
know how much food
we just renewed for another 17 years
in 73 countries
and
like saudi arabia
i'm going i mean i'm selling this stuff
50 years later that's why i always left
the last scene when michael says to me
no carly you're out of the family
business
now i own their business
i own jenko olive oil you know how funny
that is 50 years ago
if you if you go online and put it up
right now
go to quarterly owned fine italian foods
see what i own
coral you don't find italian foods so
online you can buy it
i sell gift packages all over the world
there it is hello
is that you hello
how much business does that do every
year i'm actually curious how much i can
say that in this country but but me oh
so that's basically where's it
everywhere the djenko olive oil see
jacob oliver i own the can from the
movie
that's the can
that
godfather two
when when
gennaro went over and gave the old man a
draco
he brought the cannon and he cut him up
because that's the guy that killed his
father
i own that
and do you see brando yeah
i made a deal with the brand to estate
not meeting the company i don't want to
say maybe then the irs is coming but
this company owns the worldwide rights
it's insane
it's insane now speaking of brando
you know you you because you played
carlow right now apparently there was uh
allegedly a story he didn't want you to
play carlos something happened on set
when i spoke with them what happened
with that it was not even a set
i went up
the first rehearsal oh that's how crazy
my life is another thing
in all the places they could have the
rehearsal for the godfather all the
places
they have at 119th street in harlem
apaches that tony salerno's joined i'm
there all the time
that's where they found it they want to
have it in the back room
or all kinds of italian foods going to
be served so i went up early
i come in i'm all dressed in a brownie
suit and i'm watching and who's at the
at the bar
angel cheesecake
i mean guys you can't believe real guys
tony peroxide federici i mean
everybody's there and they said what are
you doing here
i saw them here because i'm there
normally at night when they're zigging
at games because i used to bring
midnight loans they needed ten thousand
eight five thousand go and bring it to
them the games last till six in the
morning that's what i used to do jump in
the cab take money and do that's what i
i wasn't no mob guy i was an errand boy
so they said what are you doing right
i'm i'm here for the movies my movie i
see the godfather so what are you gonna
do is i'm playing carlo get out of here
you're not an actor i saw them playing
and sure enough they came out uh mr
russo rehearsal was going to start i
said i told you so i go in there
brando
they had before he brought him into the
room they said no eye contact marlon
brando nobody approached him
and then they brought god in
i mean all these young thespians marlon
brando was like their guy
was he the biggest actor in the in the
world at that point marlon no he was
but he's still recognized
for his skill
i mean what he did
so he said this guy at that time who was
in the early 70s yeah who would be the
biggest can early 70s i don't even know
but he was declining i mean after the
waterfront well i mean he anyway
long story short he comes over to me
so i say he's doing whatever he came
over to me
he says and i'm dressed i mean still
only hating
combat boots diane keaton my gardener
dress better than her i mean this is
movie stuff i mean today you see these
movie stars they they i like the old
guys where they dress every day
people see me like in beverly hills they
say where you going so what do you mean
why are you all dressed i said i'm out
there for lunch
they're in sweats they look like bums
anyway
brando says to me
you're a big tv actor no you got a big
movie coming up i said noah
he's well you're not on broadway i know
everybody on broadway i said you're
right again i said this is a quiz show
so he says who'd you study with i said
what are you talking about study what
so he calls cobra over he says francis
and i never broke down the script i got
the script i wanted to be in the movie i
think look at him being a movie star
he's questioning who you are what's your
resume why are you in this movie why am
i in this movie you knew everybody else
why they were there yeah you know
everybody said richard conte john morley
these people
yeah james khan dave scott robert duvall
jane cotton just had brian piccolo story
on tulla was the biggest stevie yet
so there's gianni russo no resume no
nothing marlo marlon brando's
questioning why you're even there right
so now i don't know protocols the first
time i'm on even a rehearsal
so i knew this guy's going to try to get
me fired
i couldn't
go to the neighborhood
everybody neighborhood i told them in
the movie already
so i said to coppola i said go over
there a minute you can't dismiss the
director not even in a rehearsal and he
left
so the whole room went dead silence they
were like you know outside the door i
said come over here a minute i put my
arm on they told me not to look at him
now i got my arm on around brando
brando's and i walked him in the back
because i don't want to embarrass him i
walk him in the back where the games
were because they knew there was no game
i'm nose to nose like this microphone
let me just tell you something mr brendo
you screwed us up for me you hear what
i'm telling you look at me
you screw this up with me i will suck on
your heart you will bleed out right here
don't do this
he stepped back and he said
that was brilliant you could really act
i was ready to whack the guy are you
crazy
he was going to change to ruin your life
and you were actually i was legitimate i
was out what would i wouldn't be sitting
here right now think about it i wouldn't
be having this company i don't want to
have nothing i mean i mean you probably
say no money but you got to realize
think about it from this standpoint
of what is the main scene you remember
from american history x
what's the main scene from american
history x there's two scenes when he
shoves his face into the concrete
concrete is one of them okay what's the
other one the monologue at the table
with his family sitting there ten
minutes yeah where edward norton just
absolutely crushes it right okay what is
the main scene from gladiator what's the
main thing give me the two main scenes
from gladiator what are the two scenes
it's gonna be most people are gonna give
the one scene from gladiator the
the scene where they're in the middle
and he fights joaquin phoenix that's the
revenge that's and then he grabs it here
and then the other scene is that you're
gonna like i've watched this scene a few
thousand times i can't get enough of it
is when he comes he turns his back he
gets on the ground and he says show your
face gladiator right he says he turns
his face it says show your face who are
you and he says i'm such and such right
you know father of
maximus um
and i will get my vengeance in this life
right so that's a scene right so you go
to these movies
there are scenes that are okay now go to
godfather go to godfather one what are
the main scenes that you remember
what are the main scenes that people
remember from godfather
this is one yeah the one the one you did
is one of them you know it's not a uh so
so to be there and then uh uh uh act
with the lineup of people that were
there maybe marlon brando wasn't peaking
at the time but brando was better like
but you know the movie today's pacino
right but you talk about who was the
lineup who did you do who was who wasn't
in the lineup right uh
khan you got
a younger but even the older guys
richard conte sterling hayden john molly
just a ridiculous lineup to be around it
what what was
i've asked this before but again
different audiences people podcast
valuetainment is
movie comes out
the day before the movie comes out
the world doesn't know who you are they
know you're from different places but
they don't know who you are well i
didn't really know me yeah well because
they knew me by the kid in fact most
people
realized i'm johnny russo were you 27 28
won the movie when you shot i was uh
yeah 27 27 okay 27 28 so you haven't yet
you've been in the circles maybe you
hung out with these guys and you know
the relationship you wouldn't be doing
the movie if you didn't have those
contacts there's no way in the world
you're gonna be picked up for this guy's
movie couple of the book all this stuff
movie comes out
you're on the big screen you're sitting
there watching it
how did life change a week later a month
later a year later
that that day
that quickly because this is a time with
no social so there is no dm
instagram facebook everywhere
and see i had a different situation that
i talk about now i didn't then
because
on june 28 1971
that day
at nine o'clock in the morning i get a
phone call from a guy called tommy
belotti
who was shot down years later with paul
castellano by john gotti in front of
sparks he was the underboss of jenna
vase family by then but then he was just
an errand boy
and he said to me are you going to the
rally the big rally that they had for
the italian defamation league the year
before they had a hundred thousand
italian americans
now they had the rally going while we
were still shooting
june 20 pull that up june 28
1961
that rally you'll you won't believe
so he says you're going to the rally i
said yeah you should know you're not
he's really talking about it i said i'm
on the dais he's i don't care if joe
colombo is sitting in your lap
you can't go
so i'm saying what i'm screwed
joe colombo got me the part
so i called barry schlondik if i didn't
call barry slotnick
and say what i'm saying to you right now
i wouldn't be here look at that rally
[Music]
that's central park south that's
columbus circle of the end
so i i tell barry i said barry give my
apologies to joe i said i can't go i
have a stomach flu thank god i thought
fast enough i can't sit anywhere but
another toilet
and i was staying at the park lane hotel
because i wanted to stay there because
well everybody's waiting outside the
door every day my apartment's two days
or two doors over i was sleeping over
there
i go out the back door on 58th street
take the subway downtown i'm not
downtown
a couple of minutes
and they
shoot joe columbo wow
then they killed they shoot the kill
they killed 13 people that day
so now they're doing the investigation
of the deus you know all the shots that
they take
there's one chair that has johnny russo
and it's empty it's got my name on it
instead of my ass on it
so now
organized crime comes looking for me fbi
comes look at me and the colombo family
want to know why i wasn't there
and junior persico who just passed in
jail
one of the toughest guys in the world
i mean he took over that family while
joe stayed in a coma for five years
over that shooting then he died
but
i had to go to the world premiere under
all of that
i snuck in and snuck out i just wanted
to be there for the pictures i didn't
sleep because as soon as i sat down they
would come and got me because they
wanted to question me
and thank god barry schlatnik i made
that call because he strained out with
the columbus but not with organized
crime
he said he had nothing to do with that
what are you talking about because they
want to know you know he's called me
they had the stomach flu but if i didn't
call barry they would have whacked me
because they figured i knew
you know they killed everybody else
the last guy they killed was an
assassination they did in uh umberto's
clan house when they shot joe gallo
because joe gallo arranged for the
shootings to kill joe columbo
i mean this thing was going on for a
while
how long did that whole thing last
during that time that time about 18
months man okay that's a long time for
that too too hello but by the way are
you familiar with the how familiar how
close are you with ray liotta
really are not closer to knock okay he's
producing uh i don't know if you're
following her or not the new american
mafia docu-series called the five
families for the history channel where
you wear this or no yeah henry hill yeah
pretty uh pretty tell us yeah
first of all i'm a big leota i love
doing oh i love ray
i don't know him that well no but i mean
there's so much going on now that's why
right now i'm
people are approaching because i want to
that hedge funds
because of i mean you heard rayo's
restaurant right in new york well when
they sold their sauce
their piece of their sauce that they
have they had two restaurants at the
time
they sold it for 411 million dollars
so i'm romancing hedge funds right now
because when i got a lot bigger and i
got 17 more i want to you know collect
coupons
and move on i got so much stuff going on
right now so but uh it's major business
are you following any of these stories
with russia ukraine you following any of
that how could you not okay
unfortunately so what do you think about
i mean you said you you had a skype call
one time you said you would i had a
skype call off a few years ago with
putin and i i got to know putin
indirectly because
his
the lady who runs
the uh embassy in new york
they eat at nellos all the time and her
son and i his son wanted me to baptize
him actually and then someone who said
her herself her son yeah and she runs
that so that's how i got to know them
and then all the russian diplomats
because of the united nations meet three
or four times a year in new york they
were always in nellos i lived one block
away from nellis on madison avenue so i
was there every day it was like my lunch
room
and
we got to talking about vodka and i used
to drink my vodka in nellos my wine all
that stuff that i produce
and he's a big godfather fan putin is
so she brought a bottle to him
when the plane went back
they gave him a bottle so
they were talking
he drank beluga black at that time i
don't know what he drinks now
and we made a bet so that's what i know
about him the other thing i know about
him is that when steven seagal was in
trouble
with warrants for
and i'm j and jules nasa was a very
close friend of mine who produced
everything with him
they got they had to get you know cigal
out of the country out because he had uh
we didn't know
he attacked young girls
in the south
and they were looking for him
fathers were
so
putin
took him in
like he did snowden
they are living in siberia now
they have no documentation no who knows
now what's going on
but uh after putin was done with the
dunas karate
that was it but they're over there
that's what i know about him that's all
i know about him really but i don't i
don't know now you know as we all knew
he was supposed to be the richest man in
the world something like 611 billion
dollars
so he deflated his own currency
yeah you're talking about 40 of it right
dropped in the last eight days
and now he's going out there wanting to
uh uh
see 60 trillion
rubles from citizens if sanctions are
tightened i mean that's a pretty crazy
story right there to say
seize
60 trillion rubles if sanctions are
tightened who does that pressure go on
the most
is that on so here's the story of
pinball february 28th in response to the
measures have taken abroad
state duama deputy from communist party
of the russian federation nicola arafi
has revealed funds placed by russian
residents will be utilized in the event
of a fresh economic collapse if they
block all the funds they are brought
then the government will have no choice
but to seize all the deposits of the
population there are about 60 trillion
rubles in order to get out of the
situation in terms of gold and foreign
currency russia now possesses around 640
billion dollars in reserves outside of
the nation apart from that 14 trillion
rubles which is 158 billion dollars and
another 470 billion in oligarchs wealth
are held in foreign banks
i mean this you get to this point it's a
level of desperation for you to go out
there and say hey 60 trillion dollars
from everybody wow being taken back what
do you think about that it's
it's becoming
increasingly obvious putin is basically
trying to make the ussr great again
you know he's he's basically
trying to sure up the eastern bloc
whatever's happening in ukraine he's
i mean talking about taking but he
created it it's interesting he's trying
to shore up but he's created the
self-fulfilling prophecy with putin i
mean he's ex kgb he i mean
look when you hear that the government
and the communist party
of the russian federation
is planning on
taking money from the people trillions
of dollars
what does this sound like i mean the
whole time the same thing biden's trying
to do
but the whole the whole premise of
communism is that the government
controls the wealth and the industry and
the capital right right the whole
premise of capitalism is that
you know individuals have the power to
do what they want with their money this
is
this is if you're a russian
communism that's what they're doing this
is very scary is it not
when you talk about putin trying to take
people's wealth well but that that's
what that's what that philosophy is
accustomed to so that's right you you
say
if they tighten sanctions i have to take
the rubles from
citizens so right now they're shutting
down
uh major networks people are walking off
yeah they're just shutting down they're
like listen we're not doing because you
can't
15 years of imprisonment if you tell
what's really going on and you call out
the government so
the media imagine living in russia right
now i don't live in russia so i don't
know what's going on over there but i
would say the media that's controlled
nationalized media
they're defending whatever positions
he's got because if you don't you are
fired right you're not going to be able
to be on air and one phone call is going
to say you're out you've got 15 years
besides but who who are the enemies
right like what is who is it the russian
tv selling as the enemy russian tv is
saying
all these sanctions look how much
they're hurting you to the point that we
have to take that money from you we're
not doing it they're doing it
they're the reason for it and you know
as crazy as it sounds a lot of people
believe that
there's a lot of their betting spoon fed
that information
otherwise the same thing is going on
here in america as well people are being
spoon-fed here's what i will say to you
that we don't know okay here's what we
don't know how many different stories
have you and i followed where at first
we emotionally oh and then later i'm
like oh my god like okay give me let's
go through a list of them 911 weapons of
mass destruction you know you go to
saddam hussein you know okay you go to
uh blm and then later on you find out
the ladies being funded and you're
buying these houses you go through
russia oh my god oh russia is this and
all what this durham dossier hillary
clinton how many so
one of the hardest things for us to do
right now it's very difficult because as
a person that's
watching this stuff
you don't really know what's going on
behind closed doors it started off don't
forget to start off a couple months ago
with biden saying russia's going to
attack you and ukrainian president
saying stop saying this you're scaring
people they're not going to do it and
it's like well they put 175 000 people
on your border what do you mean they're
not gonna attack you well no nothing's
gonna happen they put a hospital there
they put a blood bank there they're
getting ready to attack you they're not
gonna attack us then they go try to get
the airport eventually they get the
airport back
and then now
you know the next concern is is this
going to lead to a
nuclear war or not then you look at some
of the countries how they're behaving uh
uh russia's foreign minister you heard
what russia's foreign minister yesterday
said did you hear not russia's china's
foreign minister what they said
yesterday
china's foreign minister yesterday said
vladimir putin is our most important
ally
vladimir putin is our most important
ally yeah this is
the four most important strategic
partner let me say the word better he's
our most important strategic partner
china's foreign minister said that
yesterday
why are they saying that so
look at iran look at venezuela look at
china look at india look at us each is
playing a role right now okay what role
are they playing so viking just said
right now we're gonna stop all the oil
coming from russia but biden's camp just
had a meeting with
uh uh maduro to to potentially go get
oil from there and now they're having a
conversation with iran
which one of those three countries loves
america iran doesn't love america
venezuela doesn't love america why are
we doing dealings with the enemy
but we can do it in-house but we don't
want to do it in-house why i don't want
to do
peter ducey was yesterday pushing sake
on why aren't we doing it ourselves and
she snapped and she got upset and it's
like we can do it ourselves should we
just open the pipeline we got a hundred
and 100 years of reserve
right now and you've got folks that are
going to the gas station saying i can't
pay 5.35
i can't pay 5.45 well you won't give it
to trump that's all that's about well so
then india check this out what india
just did here's what's interesting about
india india avoids uh condemning putin
to get weapons for china fight what this
is a bloomberg story china fight what do
you mean china fight so obviously we
know india and china are not allies
right but we know china and russia are
top allies strategic partners quote
unquote their relationship yeah so
here's a bloomberg story yeah
quote-unquote their relationship is rock
salt india plans to avoid condemning
vladimir putin invasion of ukraine
as it needs russian weapons in its
standoff with china and officials in new
delhi are confident the u.s won't apply
much pressure moscow has been one of
india's biggest weapon suppliers since
the coal world with more than half of
india's fighter jets and almost all of
its tanks coming from the country russia
also
backed prime minister
narendra modi
hardline policies in the disputed regime
of kashmir which were widely criticized
modi's government is also confident
washington will look
the other way on this issue as india
becomes a more important u.s partner
taking on china in the asia-pacific
region the people said india is part of
so-called quad group with the u.s japan
and australia that has sought to counter
china's influence okay
but
counter so why would russia help you
then that becomes the question why would
russia help india
knowing if i help you that's going to
hurt my relationship with china it is so
complex what's going on right now that
everybody that says whatever they say
from the media i think even the sakes of
the world
you have to take everything that people
are saying and
not jump to conclusion anywhere because
the rea i don't believe anybody really
knows what the hell is going on i don't
think anybody really knows what the hell
is going on well it just comes down to
the friend of my friend is my enemy and
the enemy of my enemy is my friend not
in this case well just there's so many
today there's so many different moving
parts you have you have india who is
basically
unwilling to
talk smack or you know say anything bad
about russia because that's where
they're getting their weapons and then
china's rock solid relationship with
russia but but india is doing everything
they can to combat china's influence and
then you have this quad australia japan
united states
india right it's the strangest thing
australia
it's just there's so many different
moving parts and now they're talking
about
if the us you know wants to because they
haven't full-on gone putting sanctions
on russia's energy section like john
mccain once famously said russia is just
a gas station masquerading as a country
because that's their entire gdp gas oil
the energy section now you know you have
people like elon musk basically saying
america needs to start drilling pumping
for oil but we have it well exactly so
there's just it's it's so complicated
and then the backdrop of all this the
scary part like dylan said is is there a
nuclear war happening or there's so many
different moving parts
that the new club
is the most scary thing i mean as far as
we know they can control if they want to
lower the prices at the pump all they
have to do is just open the pipeline
again
it's here
we have it
the question is why are they not doing
it because poo
biden
biden is totally against that he closed
the day he won he closed it down
and he was did you see what elon musk
had to say about this what's that let me
read that story extraordinary times
demand extraordinary measures elon musk
says the us needs to increase oil and
gas outputs insider story
um following the russia invasion of
ukraine
um
hate to say it but we need to increase
oil and gas output immediately
extraordinary times demand extraordinary
measures says elon musk going to tweet
on friday obviously this would
negatively affect
tesla but sustainable energy solutions
cannot simply
react instantaneously to make up for
russian oil and gas exports
many countries including the us have
imposed tough sanctions on russia after
it invaded ukraine while sanctions
targeted banks oligarchs and other
financial institutions countries
refrained from sanctioning russia's
pivotal energy sector essentially using
that as a bargaining chip saying look
we're coming after you we're coming
after oligarchs we're coming after your
institutions keep [ __ ] around we're
going to go after your energy section
and now basically what did biden
announce today that the u.s has
suspended buying russian oil so
remains to be seen i mean they're
they're trying to use the energy
as leverage to go after
um putin as like a look we haven't gone
after energy yet but
don't make us do that that as like a
final straw
i mean how about all the innocent people
that are being killed in ukraine do you
think putin actually cares about that
i'm not putin how about binding in the
rest of the world that's what i'm saying
so why are you waiting for a bargaining
chip
and they're killing thousands of people
a day
that's to me i mean i don't understand
it
and where america and most people turn
to america for help
by the way then blinking makes this
comment i don't know if you saw that
where he says nato countries have green
light to send fighter jets to ukraine
that's fighting words
like that yeah that's yeah that to me is
uh uh secretary said anthony blanken
said on sunday that nato members have
the the nato state that's not the united
states yeah but not them they're saying
you guys can we're not have to go ahead
to send fighter just to ukraine as the
u.s and allies continue their efforts to
help ukraine defend itself against
russia invasion that gets a green light
blinking said uh when asked whether the
polish government of nato could send
fighter planes to ukraine in fact we're
taking we're talking with the polish
friends right now about what we might be
able to do to backfill their needs if in
fact they choose to prove these
fighter jets uh to ukraine oksana
markrova ukraine's ambassador to us said
she hopes ukraine will receive fighter
jets from poland as soon as possible so
you know
you you look at the the criticism right
okay
so
who's the who who's the f who's the
first president that uh
uh nuked japan who's the only president
ever that nuked a country is that truman
truman uh uh
and
you know if you follow the story the
other day myself tikkun dylan were
watching the story of somebody that was
getting nuked and
his grandma came and pulled him down
from the tops to go to the basement they
went in the basement and he's talking
about what he felt what it was like the
radiation what happened to some friends
what happened to people
things escalated pretty quickly right
after the what they did to pearl harbor
you know reaction hey we got to come out
and be strong
so
is truman
more aggressive than putin
i don't know
you know is truman's now
ukraine hasn't yet started attacking
you know they're just kind of like look
we just don't want to fight you man just
leave us alone let us be who we are
right
um but behind closed doors
years ago russia was saying why are you
pushing for
nato
to uh to get ukraine to be in it why are
you doing that that we don't want that
why they're not an ally to us why are
you making that happen so this this this
conversation about the way they've
negotiated with him has also been very
interesting
and then now
look here's a crazy thing you think then
you say okay in thousands of years
millions of years of us being around
whatever the thousands of years of
different empires being around
only one person's ever nuked the nation
and his name was truman democratic
president i think it was a democrat when
he uh
nuked uh uh
japan
um so what's the likelihood of that
happening okay say putin does it
if you're gonna get to that point of
doing that what would get putin to do
that would putin nuke ukraine
okay so let's go a different place
to them but but let me ask you but let
me ask you this question though here's
the other question for you uh
is okay this this is the question that i
think we have to answer because
you have to sit there and say you know
how they say innocent until proven
guilty okay
can putin do anything right now to
change his reputation worldwide
i doubt it can he do anything right not
to change his name i mean yeah stop stop
you know if he's invading ukraine of
course so right now he's a pariah in the
world let me ask you a question let's
just say he does
let's just say he does he says okay fine
let's negotiate let's get this thing i'm
going to stop right let's just say he
does
is is his reputation tainted forever
i don't think so you don't think so no
is his reputation tainted forever right
now it's his reputation is the lowest
it's probably ever been right what do
you think is his reputation tainted
forever from from other nations other
countries do you think it's already that
there's nothing he can do to make up for
the bad reputation he's got i don't
think he can salvage it at all you're
talking about nuking like he's
developing tactical nukes developing
small nuclear weapons so people are
calling them crazy no i don't think it
could be salvaged so do you think he's
sitting there right now by himself i
don't see him being as a what do you
think guy i see him being a
here's what i wanted he's a true
believer here's what we're going to be
doing he's been you know if you've seen
his documentary the guy's a he's a true
believer okay
so
do you think he's sitting there saying
thinking legacy or do you think he's
sitting there saying no you guys
understand russia is the greatest
country in the world and all of you guys
have to know who we are and you guys
been disrespecting us for a long time
everybody's playing games with us my
only allies are iran i got china on this
side and a few other countries that i'm
gonna have as my allies everybody will
screw you guys i could care less about
what you guys care about do you think
he's a legacy guy do you think he cares
what people think about him that's a
very important quality by the way he
cares about the legacy of russia perfect
so you don't think he cares what people
think about him like do you think he
cares if he walks in the streets and his
own people say you're a traitor you're a
terrible leader do you think that
bothers him no i
there's it depends who
meaning
i think you know how they're like
they're specifically sanctioning these
very very
wealthy russian oligarchs so like
let's say
you're putin and i'm your guy i'm one of
your best friends i'm one of your
closest constituents and i'm like
vlad they're taking all my money away
they're sanctioning me i can't do
business
you're close with me i feel like he
cares what these people have to say
the the people
you talk about the family the people
that are close with him the people in
the energy section you think he cares
he's talking about i'm going to take 60
trillion dollars a part of that is all
about
well that's conversation right meaning
do i i think there is some level of ego
important very important for him to care
about something
i think he has some cares for certain
people
overall what the world cares about him
clearly he doesn't care well let's take
let's take the fact that
vladimir thought he would be in and done
with ukraine in less than a week and
he's not right he he went in way over
underestimated he underestimated ukraine
how pissed off is he going to be with
his top-tier people and do you think he
really cares what they have to think
after this past nine days you you you
know you know certain people that look
you've been around a lot of the mob
folks
there's there's one thing they don't
like is what public humiliation you
don't humiliate me you got up before i
got up when we're going and leaving
dinner you don't get up before i get up
i dictate when we're leaving certain
things right hey what are you what are
you doing what are you doing grab a seat
we're not done yet this conversation
like think about that right
do you think
putin feels publicly humiliated right
now
i think so by by ukraine
like you're saying they defended
themselves i don't think he ever thought
this would be going on yet i don't think
he cares that ukraine is publicly
humiliating him i think he cares what
other people
got involved and they could have stayed
out of it that's what he's thinking not
whether it's the right thing to do or
not it's a different conversation it's
what he's thinking you right now the
world has to sit there and try to figure
out what this man is thinking and make
your next moves very carefully okay
because if he goes to the point of no
return
listen it's going to be an ugly
situation and okay so let's let's play
that let's play let's play him
not nuking and just saying you know what
let's talk about it let's play that real
quick okay so go there
in a week or two weeks they decide to
make it work
is a new person going to come and win
the election okay
he set it up in a way that he's going to
be in power for a long time
but is like what happened with hitler
eventually
at what point did hitler start losing
when his own people turn against him
has his people started turning against
them i think they will if this continues
you okay so you think they will if this
could
has been cut in half the economy is in
shambles they're going after the energy
section people are not immune to this
they have to be say they have to be
questioning
what is my guy doing i mean look at the
poll results that he's the sexiest man
in russia he's got 90 approval ratings
you know that's not true but the other
thing i think we're leaving out of the
equation we just came out of two to
three year
epidemic and pandemic that crushed
people again we didn't just have that in
the united states that was worldwide
so people been
economically hurt
for now over
almost 36 months yeah so they asked the
question and they said you know the
whole hey we're going to put sanctions
on you is that going to bother you
they're laughing at it what are you
talking about okay yeah do you know what
it is to be have a communist nation for
the longest time people are not rich
people are poor this country is used to
being poor you know all this so well
there's a group though i think there's a
group of and that i know i actually know
some of these gentlemen i met him in new
york that are billionaires because of
putin i think those are the guys are
going to say
what are we doing here
now you're destroying me personally i'm
your friend
well the whole thing with with putin is
that
he shows his power by
basically attacking or invading certain
countries this is how he you know how
they say the best way to drum up support
or approval ratings is a war right this
has been true in american history so if
you look at since 2000 right it started
with the what's the the muslim territory
in uh in russia chechnya he went in
and and cured chechnya of the muslim
terrorists right so approval waiting
ratings went up
started slipping again what did he start
he invaded crimea in 2014 when obama was
president boom so that happened approval
rating went up now approval rating has
been getting down covid economy gdp
they're no longer top ten whatever it is
all right boom ukraine this time around
the world is watching this time around
it i think it has backfired
i think it backfired on i think he's a
he's a pariah on the world stage right
now and he's never had that label he's
always been labeled a tough guy
an autocrat you know but right now it's
he's now officially a bad actor yeah but
but okay so fine
no one does no one's disagreeing with
you there
does the strategy of strong arm in that
guy work
does the strategy of strong arm in him
work today well what are you going to do
just say nothing hey good job like what
what what are you no what are their
alternatives i'm not saying other than
sanctioning it i think the only thing
that hurts him is his finances
yeah no i i it's okay with sanctions
with china what what what did it do
there's still a lot of the sanctions are
still on china how many of those
sanctions have been removed
how many sanctions have been removed
china still got the sanctions yeah biden
kept them in place okay so what's what's
happened to china's economy
are you
you see them struggling well apparently
they're the only they've been that way
all their lives they they that's what
they say that's what i'm saying to you
and and what i'm trying to say is is is
russia more like u.s or is russia more
like china china okay so they're used to
this
so all i'm saying is like you know the
the when the azerbaijan and armenia was
going through their mess do you remember
that whole thing very early year ago
exactly we're talking about it
putin pulled both of them together to
figure out a way to stop this okay
turkey had azerbaijan's back armenia had
a little bit of support from putin and
eventually they're like look we're a
small country we cannot handle going
against azerbaijan
is somebody got to try to figure these
two guys because
let's say you don't bring those two guys
in the same room together
say you don't who's affected by it
a lot of people listen a person's
irresponsible decisions in your
community
who doesn't check the stove and that
thing explodes and it catches on fire
and your community's got a bunch of
trees you're affected by it
it's not like it's just it's just that
house no no no those trees are burning
your house now that's your cost 200 000
that you got to fix now you got to move
out go stay at a hotel now those fumes
are coming into your house so somebody
has to figure out a way to
uh uh get these guys in the same room
and i know it's like oh patrick if it
was so easy somebody else would do it
all i'm saying is if you don't the
alternative sucks is all i'm saying okay
and from my experiences
of you know
dealing with whatever kind of conflicts
you're dealing with nothing uh get two
people in the room who hate each other
okay
and we're not leaving until we figure
this thing out what do we want to do
right okay well they say you don't make
friends with your friends you make
friends with your enemies right i mean
like that you make peace with your
enemies somebody's got to bring those
two together it is that important
because if this lingers it affects the
world look okay uh do you think joe
biden cares about the american people
yes okay do you think he cares about the
american people do you think he likes
the fact that a low income and middle
income families right now can't afford
to pay yes and they're paying a price i
think that is definitely a concern okay
do you think he cares why didn't he open
the pipeline do you think he cares about
that both politically as his career do
you think he also cares that as a human
being yeah i do i say yes so let's lean
towards that say he does right okay fine
um
as bad as it is right now you know the
american people oh gas prices when i did
a video a year ago gas prices are going
to go to 10 bucks you've lost your mind
you're a fear monger
okay
no problem you don't think gas prices
can go to 10 to 20 bucks you have lost
your mind if you don't think it's gonna
go there okay so this is going to affect
that's what i'm saying like there's
a role of u.s and other countries can
play to say hey listen this ain't going
to help everybody okay we got to kind of
get in front of this because the
scenario we just processed together and
we'll wrap up in eight minutes the
scenario we just processed together was
if he does
nothing
okay does a nuke we played that scenario
now let's play the truman scenario
what's the truman scenario
you don't think putin's sitting there
saying wait a minute you guys are
talking about inuk a democratic
president from u.s who apparently
democrats don't like to go to war why is
it that every time a democrat is a
president there's a war going on you
know what you nuked first
you're not this no don't make me look
bad how come you think you're so good
you started a nuclear bomb as well yours
have killed a bunch of innocent people
you make me look bad the word looks at
you that's what he's thinking not
whether it's true or not it's irrelevant
that's what he's thinking let's play the
game and this is not a game let's say
this scenario takes place it's
say he does use one of his
nuclear bombs go there
say it happen you have to think about
this
say he does what happens where does he
use it
kiev
okay why would why would he nuke kiev
it's not this is not a why question if
he's saying you get in my way just so
you know i have this thing called the
nuclear weapons he's not saying that to
say
hey
if you get on my way
i have this thing because it's a cool
toy i got no i'm going to wipe your ass
out yeah but that toy can
really affect poland also i mean you
have two men so when we bombed
hiroshima
it was ridiculous we had no effect there
was no residual to the united states
when truman dropped the bomb over there
stop the war yeah but over there
europe is so interwound you're
protecting different countries
neighboring hello okay of course okay
cool so that's a good point i mean the
answer is nato i mean it's okay that's
like the
the beautiful part of the united states
is who are our neighbors canada mexico
yeah like we got oceans on each side
we're going to be okay right now that's
why he did it but who were who who putin
needs to be i mean putin's major concern
is nato and he doesn't want nato
expanding and he doesn't want all these
countries that are considering joining
nato
ukraine finland some of these other
countries uh in that region
these guys are all nuke ready for russia
let's go back to one thing that you said
you don't think it's important to me
what the united states has nukes in all
those countries i get that i'm about to
give you a step but the bottom line is
to me everything we're talking about
has nothing to do with the american
people the american people right now are
suffering to the gas tank
and biden can open the pipeline but the
question is helped the question why
isn't he doing it oh no no but that's
not the question you're right that
solves the american problem that's what
i'm talking about i'm more worried about
america first yeah sorry no no
everybody is
well that's the number one thought of
we're all thinking america first all i'm
saying is
if there is a problem
in somebody else that it affects where
it affects because a nuclear bomb in
ukraine what happens next who reacts
how ugly can it get
you have to play those cards
if you if he ends up going there what
happens but
if he does that i mean the only language
that this guy speaks
is
war
and toughness the only like
he's you're not gonna peacefully
negotiate with this guy the only thing
like how trump said when kim jong-un oh
you think you're tough i got a lot about
what's the famous line oh you think my
boss my mom's actually worked yeah okay
putin understands listen if i do this
there's ramifications and that's the
only language he speaks and then as far
as what the american people are
concerned with what's a bigger issue
for the lineage and the legacy of
america higher gas prices for six months
or tyranny taking over europe in my
opinion that is way more important than
paying a dollar more in gas
that's the bigger issue whether gas is a
little more expensive for the next six
months but it don't have to be that's
the problem i have with it all i'm i'm
you know like i i'm we all know i'm a
lot older than you guys i've seen so
many things go on
all through my life
we have a solution for the people who
just came out of a pandemic
they can't afford five dollars six
dollars a guy they got to go to work
i i'm seeing it reacting
and we can handle it why are we handling
that for our own people now let the rest
of the world what putin's going to do we
don't control
we can't control it and we're not really
going to be a result of it if he nukes
that whole area
i mean we're going to lose certain
supplies or whatever but there's nothing
that we cannot produce ourselves we're
self-sustaining
so why don't we just go back to our own
business for right now to take care of
the little guy
who's the population in the united
states that needs to go to work needs to
buy gas at maybe 250
three dollars
where is it going to go like
you're saying patrick it can go to ten
dollars but what does that how does that
help us oh that's that's gonna be that's
gonna be catastrophic if that hits here
uh and and they can't like i don't
understand why they're not doing it
because
gas prices right now being the highest
like every time you read one of these
things so how do you think about gas
prices how do you think gas prices are
high this is not left right middle
doesn't help no matter who the president
is when the gas prices are right this is
going to destroy midterms i think i
think i would not be surprised if they
fixed this in the next 30 60 90 days i
totally agree with you did you see did
you see what uh uh bernie tweeted out
but but here's
what the strategy is and it's it's
people are not gonna fall for this
here's what bernie tweeted today okay
bernie tweeted today oil company revenue
since last year exxon up 57
chevron up 84
shell is up 49 bp is up 45 percent we
cannot allow big oil companies to
continue to take advantage of war in
ukraine and inflation to make huge
profits by jacking up gas prices we need
a windfall profit tax every time
you come up with certain policies your
handling of afghanistan then gas prices
go up oh it's the capitalist fault no
gas prices were down yeah he's not
mentioning the fact that the gas price
is gone what are you talking about so
these guys made a ton of money in oh not
in 19 without it being gas prices were
two bucks right what the hell are you
talking about
so all i'm saying is they point it's
like i gotta blame this guy i gotta
blame that guy i gotta blame this guy i
gotta pete buddha change is like oh you
listen
you look you're having a hard time don't
worry about it just go buy a a electric
car it's gonna be okay go buy an
electric cup everyone should do a
thousand
hell are you talking about yeah so i
agree with that all i'm saying is
that uh you know i think uh
i think the approach look we know
putin's not afraid of biden
we know
she is not afraid of biden we know that
for a fact we know the taliban is not
afraid of biden no they took 80 billion
dollars of stuff we know
nobody fears the current president they
don't they just don't fear
the current president they're going and
doing whatever they're doing and taking
whatever they want right that's just
what they're doing china's looking at
russia as a case study that's all
they're doing china's looking i said
okay so they did this so they did this
or they did something for taiwan of
course there's a case study so is it is
it that they're looking at the president
and they don't fear him or they like at
the end of the day they need to fear the
united states military no you and the
general first of all and our and our
troops that's not how it works though
that's not how it works
first of all you have to realize like
you know uh uh
you felt bush would come out and be
strong or reagan would come out and be
strong you felt jfk would come out and
be strong you felt trump would come out
and be strong and
you know say his thoughts about some of
these guys i don't think they're that
worried i think they're looking at an
opportunity right now they're just
trying to take advantage of that you all
have deals with them already
all i hope is all i hope is
that
you know the one good thing with him is
the benefit is the fact that he's he's
chill
i hope that chill
is used in a proper way
to kind of you know
uh because at least a trump may publicly
humiliate to produce a reaction i hope
something like that doesn't happen here
because i don't think public humiliation
uh i think you gotta you gotta take a
different approach
putin i think uh no i think biden is not
somebody that's going to rub you or ego
he's not going to be like he's not
you're in a room right now with a bunch
of different egos biden's ego is not
going to output your ego you understand
what i'm saying like he's not going to
be not emotional
no i no no i don't think he has
you know uh look bernie sanders was
supposed to win the the primaries
everybody was ahead of him he was fifth
place last minute buddhich everybody
drops out warren amy everybody drops out
to make this guy this guy was not the
one that had the biggest ego to be a
president he was selected by the
democratic party to say he's the best
one that can go win it because he was a
former vp this is not a president guy
this is a number two three four five
guys not another one
so all i'm saying is there could be a
benefit in him not having a big ego
that's all i'm saying there could be a
benefit in him and not having a big ego
because he may not offend putin to do
something i don't know i may be wrong
i'm just speculating the terminology
that they often use and this they say
that this is that this is actually a
great quality for presidents
is measured and that's what a lot of
people would say about
trump that his flaws is that he was not
measured it was all reactionary he's all
emotional
here's the difference with trump here's
the difference with trump with trump
you don't even try
because you don't want to know i don't
know if that makes sense or not you
don't even try taliban afghanistan
because you do not want to know rasam
soleimani yeah that guy was supposed to
be the next leader
and what did iran do nothing
yeah nothing no no
nothing right so the benefit of having a
guy like that is people won't even test
you
the the the but the benefit that if they
do
he's going to say some stuff that's
going to upset the enemy but you're just
not going to test you're going to say
let me be waiting for the next prayer
anyways uh we are up gang uh gianni
thank you so much for coming out kidding
i really enjoy every time we're talking
your stories thank you for your
privilege just so you know i have a
feeling tonight i know what adam's going
to fantasize about tonight when he goes
to sleep marilyn monroe what are we
talking about you're going to be
thinking about a 15 and a half year old
the stories you have
like pat says if ten percent of them are
true you've lived the most ridiculous
life and something tells me they're all
true a guy like you in the mob
affiliated with the mob hospitality
nightlife and hollywood and i had never
tried it was the people i associated
myself with they gave me the privileges
listen i wouldn't done ten percent of
this well they say that your network is
your net worth and clearly you get the
the right network well here's what we've
got thank you for coming out folks
tomorrow
it's going to be a very extensive
podcast because tomorrow we are bringing
the former kgb member jack barski to
talk about what's going on with ukraine
and
russia i highly suggest you not miss
tomorrow's
him and i've been going back and forth
back and forth back and forth he's going
to be live right here with us the next
day i believe liz wheeler is going to be
here and i can't tell you who's going to
be here on friday i can't even tell you
what time the podcast's going to be on
friday and you'll know why once it
happens because a request has been made
but
you kind of don't want to miss friday's
podcast is that fair that's very true
you kind of don't want to miss friday's
podcast the world's going to know who it
is when we do it on friday having said
that take care everybody we'll see you
guys tomorrow same time 9 o'clock with
jack barski bye bye bye bye johnny
you